so I was to the baby
Thanks thanks for coming I guess that's
a that was a bit of a surprise the
microphone coming on it sounds a little
weird it's you lower it okay I'm not
sure we need the amplification in the
room actually it's a small room but
anyway thanks for coming I was a little
worried that no one was gonna show up
this morning because apparently what I
think of as real time has almost nothing
to do with this workshop because there
was very little of it yesterday but
we'll see maybe he'll be able to make
some connections so let me give you a
little bit of background I the work that
I'm going to be talking about is his
work that's going on in a research
center that's headquartered here at
Berkeley called Terra swarm and it's
focused on the technology of systems
that integrate sensors and actuators
into computing and networking systems so
this this particular picture is one
that's been used by a lot of people to
kind of explain the idea it comes from
young rabbi but the idea is that you've
got you know the cloud backbone
you've got the primarily user interface
devices handhelds PCs and so on and then
what young called the swarm at the edge
of the cloud which are all the sensors
and actuators that are then interacting
with the physical world okay so it's a
pretty large research center there's
nine universities involved and the you
know it's a I would say about 40 percent
of the work is going on at Berkeley but
it's got it covers an enormous dynamic
range all the way from people who are
really primarily focused on the sensor
and actuator devices all the way up to
machine learning people who are you know
using cloud infrastructure and doing
anomaly detection like what we heard
about yesterday on sensing and actuation
so the intellectual focus of this Center
is on what a lot of people these days
are calling cyber physical systems
because it's primarily about systems
that integrate both physical dynamics
through sensing and actuation with
computation and networking and you know
the key observation is that this really
underlies most of the industrial economy
today it's really hard to find an
industry that isn't doing cyber-physical
systems in some sense because they're
you know putting computing into
everything and of course that you know
the the really high visibility things
are self-driving cars smart grid
manufacturing systems biomedical systems
all of these are really very much
becoming cyber-physical systems and the
interesting thing about this from my
perspective as a research area is that
it it is full of contradictions
there's contradictory requirements
throughout you need systems to be
adaptable but you need them to be
repeatable because they're safety
critical often you need high
connectivity but you need security and
privacy you need high performance but
you need low energy ok you need a
synchrony but you need coordination and
cooperation you need scalability but you
also need reliability and predictability
you've got laws and regulations you've
got technical possibilities these are
often very much at odds with one another
and so on the the particular
contradiction that I'd like to focus on
today is in in the notion of what a
process is there are really profound
differences between the computer science
view of what a process is and the rest
of engineering the rest of engineering
thinks of dynamics the evolution of the
state of a system over time whereas
computer science primarily focuses on
algorithms these are very different ways
of thinking about the dynamics of a
system and they don't mesh together very
well at all and this is really the
essence of what I'd like to talk about
today in my opinion you know these
contradictions are really they demand
innovation and it's a wonderful area to
be doing research and for that reason I
was pretty disappointed in in the talk
yesterday because in fact Harvey perhaps
led you to believe that there are no
real time problems in the Large Hadron
Collider
there's just big data problems huge data
enormous data problems right but what he
described were not real time problems
that's simply not true the Large Hadron
Collider is doing some enormous ly
innovative stuff with real time one of
the one of their recent innovations is
this White Rabbit project at CERN where
they synchronize clocks around this 27
kilometer ring okay to Precision's of
about 80 Pico seconds which at the speed
of light is about this far so that means
that you ask two clocks that are 10
kilometers apart what the current time
of day is and they will agree within
about 80 Pico seconds on what the
current time of day is CERN uses this to
orchestrate the controllers and to
timestamp the sensing throughout the 27
kilometer ring okay you can do
orchestration at a distance 2 machines
10 kilometers apart that can act in
synchrony at Precision's of tens of Pico
seconds even though the speed of light
makes it kind of impossible to
coordinate that directly this technology
was used by a graduate student that CERN
to expose the flaw in the experiment a
couple of years ago that purported to
demonstrate that neutrinos were
traveling faster than the speed of light
and so this is a very profound
innovation I think and this ability to
synchronize clocks at very high
precision I I believe is actually going
to pervade all of our networks I think I
predict that within a few years anything
that's on a network is going to have a
clock synchronized with everything else
that's on a network to Precision's
probably globally of on the scale of
microseconds and in my view that
profoundly changes what you can do in
with distributed computing systems it's
extremely difficult to measure these ok
there's quite an art to making the
measurements to determine the the
synchrony of the clocks
they even do it the they have to put the
the devices side-by-side and they put 10
kilometers of cable coiled on the floor
between them okay and then they have
temperature-compensated oscilloscope
probes where the wire lengths are very
precisely measured to be exactly the
same length they've they use extremely
expensive hardware where the the
amplifiers that are used in the
oscilloscope are all calibrated to very
high precision it's extremely difficult
to do these measurements okay so it
turns out that the clock synchronization
precision depends only on the asymmetry
and the latencies in the communication
it doesn't actually depend on the
latency so if you can if the latency
between a communication from A to B is
the same as from B to a then you can
perfectly synchronize the clocks okay so
what they they run Ethernet over fibre
in this network and they use the same
fibre for both directions so the
temperature effects are the same in both
directions
okay so what is real time all right
so in my view real time refers to the
time of the physical world okay which
was missing in all of the talks
yesterday nobody talked about the time
of the physical oral okay there's a of
course a rabbit hole I could go down
what do we mean by the time of the
physical world well you'll have to you
know invite Stephen Hawking to explain
that one right so I I think there's a
few useless observations and oh sorry I
have where I have a handout okay because
I don't want to talk about these useless
observations but I've written a one-page
document on why these these views of
time are useless so if you'd like to if
you'd like to read about it I won't take
the time now okay you see this all the
time though a lot of time is a resource
like any other in computing you know we
have resources we have to manage
resources so time is a resource it's not
you can read the one-page paper okay so
let's talk about more useful notions of
what real time is well I'll try to go
through each of these but some of them
I'm going to go through rather quickly
because they all have rather different
implications on how you approach the
computing problem of course the simplest
one is just fast computation right if
you do things fast that you can that it
that does have a connection with real
time in the physical world of course but
it's not a very interesting notion of
real time in the sense that well it's
interesting because it's interesting to
everybody right it's everyone wants
faster computation so it doesn't
distinguish the problem and I don't need
to take your time to talk about it so
I'm not going to talk about it in the
classical area of real-time computing
that area is primarily about operating
systems scheduling prioritize scheduling
assign priorities to tasks and run them
in a multi-threaded environment to me
this is also not a very interesting
interpretation of real time it's it is
literally the most established notion of
real-time computing
but it suffers from all the problems of
multi-threaded computing plus new ones
brittleness priority inversion
non-monotonic anomalies etc I don't
think it offers a very good solution to
the real-time problem and so I'm not
going to talk about that either so this
one gets a little more interesting and
this one we did see yesterday ok
computation on streaming data alright so
what do I mean by streaming data
well there's streaming data from the
matrix if you remember the movie ok the
key idea is that the data is unbounded
it's not just big right it's gonna keep
coming at you forever you might as well
be thinking of it as infinite data not
not bounded data and in contrast to
Ronit talk yesterday you can't do random
access on the input data you don't
actually have the data but it's
streaming at you from sensors and it's
going to keep coming you don't have the
whole data set and yet you want to be
able to do queries on that on that
infinite data set ok from the
perspective of computing in this context
halting is a defect not you know I mean
in the Turing Church thesis all halting
programs are equivalent here it's the
other way around you know all halting
programs are defective you need
algorithms that operate on incomplete
data and some of the best work I've seen
recently really creative stuff by rajeev
allure at penn who shows how you can
take algorithms that are sort of like
classic search algorithms that have been
developed for operating on finite data
sets even big finite data sets and
actually adapt these algorithms so they
operate on infinite data sets and
there's interesting problems about how
you keep the state of the algorithms
bounded even though the data over which
they're operating is unbounded very nice
work by rajeev allure to me one of the
interesting things about operating on
streaming data is that it implies
different software architectures so you
know the sort of established way of
component izing software these days is
using object-oriented methods where you
bundle
data and methods and the way that you
interact with a software component is a
transfer of control you call a procedure
and you get a return value any man that
possibly manipulates the data that's not
a very good way to componentize
operations on streaming data it's a very
procedural view of a software component
and so there's a whole class of other
kinds of software components that are
fall under the category of actor
oriented where you stream data through
the component instead of streaming
control through the component you don't
transfer control to it you just sequence
data through it it's a more
intrinsically concurrent way of thinking
about the software architecture there's
a lot of subtle questions that come up
when you put these things together so
for example if I think of these four
things these three boxes here as
processes that are operating on
streaming data what does it mean when
you have two streams of data converging
on a single process okay I mean a really
naive thing to do is well
non-deterministic interleaving well but
that has a lot of implications that can
be really problematic right so you might
instead want for example to timestamp
the data on these streams in order to
define a meaning for the interleaving of
the converging streams all right how you
bound the state of these objects even
though they're operating on an infinite
amount of data or at least an unbounded
amount of data how is feedback handled
so the interactivity that Leonard talked
about yesterday can be thought of as
this kind of loop in streaming data okay
so these feedback loops create some
interesting semantic problems there's a
lot of beautiful theory in process
algebras for talking about how you for
analyzing those kinds of feedback
interactions you can generalize the
notion of streams to multi-dimensional
streams a stream naively is a single
sequence but you could have a partial
order of components in a stream okay
where the dependencies between the data
but the data is progressing in multiple
dimensions at once
and to me one of the most interesting
things is assigning a semantics of time
to these streams so for example time
stamping the data and then treating that
as part of the semantics of the stream
so I could probably give you a whole
talk on each of these but I'm not going
to do that I actually teach a graduate
course that goes into this and quite a
lot of detail that I'll be offering next
spring okay so let's go on to the next
notion of a real-time bounded execution
time the key issue here is that we have
chosen in computing a semantics of
software where the notion of correct
execution of a program has nothing to do
with how long it takes to do anything
the timing is irrelevant to the
correctness it's the semantics of every
widely used programming language has
this property okay so timing emerges
from the implementation when you build a
piece of software and run it on a piece
of hardware then you get timing it's not
part of the design okay
now this has some pretty serious
implications for cyber-physical systems
so one of my favorite examples of the
implications comes from fly-by-wire
aircraft
so the first fly-by-wire aircraft was
the Airbus a320 which started flying in
in around 1985 and you know fly-by-wire
aircraft computers mediate the pilot
commands and then directly control the
actuators and sense data can alter the
what how the computers interpret the the
command so for example in the Airbus
a320 the computers implement a flight
envelope protection that makes it
impossible for the pilot to put the
plane in a stall okay the pilot can pull
back on the stick try to you know pull
up the nose at a certain point the
computers won't let it happen
actually Airbus also dispensed with the
stick so they changed the user interface
when they went with fly-by-wire boeing
did not
okay the one of the most recent probably
the most recent fly-by-wire aircraft is
the Boeing 787 so I heard a story from a
guy who worked on the Boeing 777 which
was their first fly-by-wire aircraft the
one preceding the 787 and the 777
started flying in in 95 and Boeing
estimated that they would be making this
plane for about 50 years okay that's a
typical production run for a commercial
aircraft 50 years they make it and then
it runs it flies for another 50 years
probably okay so you're talking about a
hundred years of production and
maintenance in in the early 1990s Boeing
stockpiled all of the micro processors
that they're going to need for the 50
year production run of the plane plus a
hundred years of maintenance okay Boeing
777s are selling what very well right
now you can buy one if you have enough
money okay and the flight control system
will use microprocessors that were made
in the early 1990s the one rolling off
the production line in the year 2030
will use microprocessors made in the
early 1990s
why because you can update that
microprocessor and it will correctly run
the software but the behavior of the
system will change
I guarantee it okay because the software
in fact doesn't specify the behavior
it's just incomplete okay this to me is
a profound embarrassment okay I think
that our engineering tools are just not
up to the job you know we do have
beautiful ways of abstracting away the
details of the hardware right we you got
a microprocessor well we have an
instruction set architecture so you
don't have to worry about which version
of the microprocessor you're dealing
with you can put in a bytecode
interpreter with a just-in-time compiler
that only has to worry about what the
instruction set architecture is the
compiler that produces the bytecode only
has to worry about the byte code
specification etc etc we've got all
these layers of abstraction there
beautiful
right and for the engineers at Boeing
every one of these layers of abstraction
failed okay the implementation the
design is actually the implementation
there is no design on paper there's just
a design in Silicon and wires it's a
prototype and hack kind of style of
design and it's not because those guys
are incompetent at Boeing it's because
we haven't given them the tools to do it
right okay so we could try raising the
level of abstraction and you know
introduce something higher than this but
that's going to be really problematic
because the foundations are missing or
any control over timing okay so give you
a story this is an old story this is
from 2001 okay and and micro processors
that are used in in these kinds of
systems have gotten a lot more complex
since 2001 but it's a beautiful story
because these guys did an analysis of a
piece of safety critical control
software for an aircraft that was less
than two pages of code okay less than
two pages of code running on a
particular microprocessor they had to
construct a very detailed model of the
CPU in order to be able to come up with
a formal formulation of the worst case
execution time problem for it for the
chunks of code that we're executing
worst case execution time okay
the problem that they report in this
paper turns into an integer linear
program a rather large one okay rather
difficult to solve okay
capturing the precise interactions with
the cache etc interestingly they had to
make a bunch of assumptions one of the
assumptions was that there was no IO
happening okay that's interesting why do
you care about timing because you care
about the interaction with the outside
world but you can only say something
about timing if you're not interacting
with the outside world okay this is
absurd and this is the situation that
people are in right now who are trying
to design these systems they have this
fiction worst case execution time all
the theory people who do
you know that's prioritized scheduling
always say Oh assume you've got worst
case execution time of this chunk of
code and then you can come up with
scheduling policies but of course you
don't have a worst case execution time
it's a fiction now the fact is that the
electronics on which we build computers
is actually capable of delivering very
precise and reliable timing it's the
software abstractions above it that
discard that capability okay so this
takes me to the next notion which is
maybe we really need a temporal
semantics in programs okay so how would
we accomplish that I contend that
actually the only rigorous way to
accomplish that is to look through the
whole abstraction stack and try to take
this property that the electronics
technology actually is capable of
delivering reliable and precise timing
and figure out how to expose that at the
programming model level okay so we
started a project like this a few years
ago that it was focused on control over
execution time and the key idea of this
project was that given that the hardware
is capable right how can we get that
capability exposed in the software so we
came up with a name for the project
which is prepped okay
it's a beautiful acronym because it
means several different things at least
five different meanings its precision
time processors or predictable and
repeatable timing or performance with
repeatable timing you can always get
repeatable timing if you don't care
about performance right you just way
over engineer the system that's by the
way how it's done today okay enormous
head rooms in the designs because
there's no other way to do it today the
the fourth meaning is of course the
French word for ready which has a timing
notion and the Dutch word prep means fun
it's a fun project okay
there's significant challenges with this
and there are really computer
architecture challenges right how do you
design deep pipelines while maintaining
control over timing how do you get
memory hierarchies without getting the
uncontrollable variability that cache
misses cause cause how do you do i oh
the primary mechanism that is that uses
i/o these that is the primary mechanism
providing i/o is interrupts and
interrupts are enormous ly disruptive to
timing and extremely difficult to
control okay so we have shown that these
problems are all solvable okay and again
it would take a whole talk to explain it
we've created three generations of prep
machines the most recent one in my view
kind of sews up the problem and in fact
we declared this project finished in
2015 last year and we've been trying to
get people in industry to pick up on it
to commercialize this but this is a risk
five based open-source implementation of
a prep machine and the interesting thing
about this implementation is that it
demonstrably has no performance cost
okay in fact it has slightly better
performance than a comparable RISC 5
processor under the assumption that
you've got enough concurrency to be able
to keep the pipeline busy in the full
time ok then you actually get a
performance improvement but again I it
would take a whole different talk to to
talk about it what I'd like to do is is
explain really what the benefits are if
you can get control over timing at the
instruction set architecture level you
can improve the determinism of programs
this is important for cyber physical
interactions but I also believe that
it's important for concurrent software
ok if you can get repeatable behavior
out of concurrent software that could be
a very valuable property and if you can
control timing you can get repeatable
behavior out of concurrent software you
can achieve hard real-time with a lot
less over-designed
you don't need all that engineering
Headroom which by the way can
significantly reduce your energy cost
because you don't have to clock your
processor at 2.4 gigahertz you just have
to clock it fast enough to meet your
real time constraints okay and it can
significantly reduce your costs it
offers the potential for certifiable
safety so in particular to address the
air the the aircraft problem you could
have software that will at its io
boundaries behave exactly the same way
when you update the microprocessor okay
because you can control the timing of
those external interactions and
consequently you could actually certify
the software rather than certifying the
whole Hardware design down to the
silicon and wires wonderful question how
do you expose control over timing at the
programming level and interestingly
there's a lot of people who have tried
to do this in the past
none of them by the way by actually
modifying the architecture to actually
give you control over timing but
nevertheless there's a rich extensive
graveyard of real-time languages that
all have a real-time semantics that we
can learn from okay but in my view the
missing ingredient here and the reason
that these things never succeeded is
they were not built on a solid
foundation you didn't actually have
control over the timing you just had the
illusion of control over the timing okay
so portable software I mentioned that
and actually you can get improved
performance because you a limit you can
eliminate pipeline bubbles you can get
less synchronization overhead right if
you can control timing in two
independent processes then you can
control when they interact without
having to use semaphores okay so for
certain kinds of applications you can
really dramatically improve the
performance and eliminate all that
synchronization overhead at yeah so
anyway I think I believe there's a lot
of benefits to this from a research
perspective we have basically declared
this project finished and my strategy at
this point is to try to get industry to
pick it up TI is very interested
National Instruments has picked it up it
in the form of soft cores and so we're
optimistic that it'll get out there in
the real world before too long okay so
I'd like to spend my last 15 minutes on
what I think is actually the biggest of
these okay which is how do you get
temporal semantics in networks and this
one you know I I talked about the CERN
white rabbit project where they
synchronize clocks synchronizing clocks
is a good starting point but it doesn't
really give you time semantics in
networks the question is going to be is
going to have to be you know if you if
you have these synchronize clocks how
are you going to use them okay so let me
talk a little bit about that so here is
a very nice example of a cyber-physical
system that uses a technology that's
similar to what CERN is using so I want
to emphasize that this isn't just you
know turns effort isn't just an esoteric
little side thing that's happening
somewhere this is a printing press made
by Rush Bosch Rexroth and it's a machine
about the size of this room and it has a
couple hundred microcontrollers in it
that are all networked using cat5
Ethernet for the networking and running
tcp/ip okay this Bosch Rexroth started
making this printing press in 2008 and
at that time nobody in industrial
automation was using Ethernet and tcp/ip
because they weren't designed for that
they're not you don't have control over
timing you use you use canned buses
instead or some network that's
specifically designed for industrial
automation but these guys said well no
actually we can use Ethernet and tcp/ip
but the key thing that they did is they
ran this same clock synchronization
protocol that CERN was using okay which
runs over tcp/ip and they synchronize
the clocks on all of these micro
processors and then they orchestrate the
use of the network so that they never
get packet drops packet drops in modern
Ethernet networks occur because buffers
overflow in switches and if you can
orchestrate the use of the network you
can prevent buffer overflow
moreover you can orbit by orchestrating
the use of the network you can get
deterministic latencies so you can now
actually have communication over these
micro processors where they're
orchestrating their actions in the
physical world over a network that is
using basically Internet technology now
this idea of making this use of the
network deterministic is really the key
thing that I'd like to focus on for my
remaining 13 minutes okay because it's
it's a very controversial approach you
know when I talk to people about using
deterministic models for cyber-physical
systems it rubs them the wrong way okay
but I'd like to convince you that it's
actually the right thing to do so my
claim is that some of the most valuable
models that we have are in fact
deterministic models okay so what is a
deterministic model well a deterministic
model is one where if you're given an
initial state and you're given the
inputs then the model defines exactly
one behavior this is a pretty vague
definition because in order to nail this
down you have to define state you have
to define inputs and you have to define
outputs okay or behavior rather okay
these things have to be defined and if
you define them formally then you can
determine whether a model is
deterministic or not if you don't define
them formally this definition is
meaningless all right my claim is that
deterministic models have proved
extremely valuable in the past in fact I
think they underlie the Industrial
Revolution and the information
technology revolution so some examples I
already mentioned instruction set
architectures instruction set
architectures are a deterministic model
of an underlying non-deterministic
system why is the underlying system
non-deterministic well ultimately its
electrons sloshing around in silicon and
metal right that's what it is and any
particular realization of a
microprocessor has really no assurance
that it will correctly execute the
software that it runs right you can get
a no alpha particle that
flip flip a bit in the program counter
and all hell breaks loose the physical
world is going to exhibit
non-deterministic behavior but the
instruction set architecture defines a
deterministic model that overlays that
non-deterministic physical reality and
it's proved extremely useful it gives a
very solid target for a compiler
designer for example all right in
cyber-physical systems does it make
sense to use deterministic models so if
you look at the Bosch Rexroth printing
press it's got some micro processors
compute are communicating over a network
fabric and interacting with a physical
plant by the way the paper flies through
this printing press at about a hundred
kilometers per hour okay
the ink is deposited at micron precision
on that paper as it flies by the paper
roll that feeds the printing press is
about two meters in diameter and weighs
a couple of tonnes and when the paper
roll runs out you don't want to shut
down the printing press the printing
press ideally operates 24/7
it's just cranking out books constantly
okay so when the paper roll is getting
small a forklift comes in loads a paper
roll on a spare spindle and then the
computers spin up the new paper roll so
that its speed matches the old paper
roll and then just before the old paper
roll runs out this device called a
flying paster lays down double-sided
tape glues the new paper to the old and
it feeds it through and cuts the old and
then feeds it through without missing a
beat and all of this happens so that the
seam occurs between pages of whatever's
being printed which was uploaded to a
website as a PDF file okay
very tight orchestration required to
pull this off and if something goes
wrong well it can be disastrous right so
you you have to design these systems to
anticipate all kinds of possible
failures in the physical in the physical
plane okay so you've got these
computational platforms Network fabric
physical plant there's lots of sources
of non-determinism in here you could get
packet losses you know Bosch Rexroth
managed to get rid of them unknowable
delays
well again they were delivered living in
a walled garden right so their Ethernet
wasn't connected to the Internet and so
that made it a lot easier to do that you
have uncontrollable scheduling in the
computational platform unknowable
execution times of course whenever you
interact with the physical world you
have imperfect actuation you have parts
failures and you have physical noise
lots of sources of non-determinism so a
lot of people come to me and say well
alright given all these sources of non
determinism it doesn't make sense to
even talk about deterministic models for
these systems you should instead assume
non determinism and design your system
to be robust and tolerant of this non
determinism I don't buy it and the
reason I don't buy it is because there's
a distinction between models and reality
ok what is the role of models well
here's a model this is Newton's second
law F equals MA describing the dynamics
of a physical object under forces okay
and this is a physical realization so
the model is constructed in a modeling
framework in this case the calculus of
Newton's laws and the fidelity of the
model is how well the model and its
target match right it's okay Engineers
often confuse the model in the target
they think they're talking about the
model but they're actually talking about
the target or vice-versa
okay and there's a famous quote that you
probably heard by Solomon ghulam from
USC who famously said you will never
strike oil by drilling through the map
to emphasize that it really is important
to keep the distinction between the
model and the thing being modeled I'd
like to point out that this does not in
any way diminish the value of a map okay
it's just that you have to know whether
you're talking about the map or the
desert there are two different things
the map of course is always wrong it's
never it's fidelity is never perfect
so another famous quote comes from box
and Draper who have written a lot about
the use of models in science and
engineering and they say essentially all
models are wrong but some are useful
okay you'll never get perfect fidelity
so if we're not after perfect fidelity
the
can we make deterministic models of
these kinds of systems that are useful
right we're not trying to make models
that are right that's not possible we're
trying to make models that are useful
okay so we should draw on the best
available models right of course you
we've got a whole tradition on the cyber
side a whole tradition on the physical
side let's see if we can use the models
that people have come up with there well
from this perspective software is a
model and single threaded imperative
programs are in fact a deterministic
model notice that the in order to call
them a deterministic model I have to
eliminate time right the input the time
at which the input arrives is not
relevant the time at which the output
arrives is not relevant okay
and under those assumptions within that
modeling framework single threaded
imperative programs are in fact a
deterministic model even though the
underlying physical system really is
never deterministic I mean there's
always Murphy's Law to contend with
right now this particular deterministic
model depends very heavily on the
instruction set architecture model which
is also a deterministic model and the
ability that compiler designers have of
constructing correct compilers depends
on the determinism of both of these
models okay we really wouldn't have the
compilers that we have today if these
models were not deterministic the
instruction set architecture depends on
another underlying deterministic model
which is synchronous digital logic
design this is a Intel Haswell quad-core
chip with a GPU so five cores on each
die 1.7 billion transistors here okay
worked on the first tape out no no
errors right relying very heavily on the
determinism of this model and the
ability to create silicon structures
that are faithful to the model notice my
weird turn of a phrase I built a
physical system that was faithful to the
model rather than building a model that
was faithful faithful to the physical
system
that's what Intel does when they design
a chip they build a model and then they
build a physical system that is faithful
to that model now what about this the
physical side of cyber-physical systems
well we also have deterministic models
they're very powerful they're very
useful differential equations are used
by mechanical engineers as the
bread-and-butter of how you know to
design the dynamics of a system these
are deterministic models they are like
all other models wrong and the target is
a non deterministic system the essential
problem for cyber-physical systems is
this one you take the best deterministic
models from the cyber side and you put
them together with the best
deterministic models from the physical
side and the combination is
non-deterministic always because these
models say nothing about timing these
models are all about timing as soon as
you put them together you've got a non
deterministic model so we don't have
deterministic models for cyber physical
systems determinism really is it makes
sense to insist on deterministic models
so in science the value of a model lies
in how well its behavior matches that of
a physical system right that's why we
build models but in engineering the
value of a physical system lies in how
well its behavior matches that of the
model if I give you a piece of silicon
that doesn't behave like that
synchronous digital logic circuit it's a
piece of junk ok these are complementary
uses of models now I contend that most
scientists and most engineering is
actually engineers use models both ways
an engineer will use models in the
scientific sense where you're trying to
construct a model of the physical system
and you need it to be faithful and a
scientist will use models in the
engineering sense they'll construct a
model of something they want to build to
control that Large Hadron Collider and
then they'll build it ok so both styles
of modeling are used in both science and
engineering but they are different uses
of models
and it's important to understand which
use of models you're using your how are
you using your models okay so here's a
model of Newton's Cradle
you can tell that it's a model because
it's too perfect and it's you know it's
beautifully rendered in this nice
graphics engine that does the shadowing
and it's overlaid on top of a copy of
newton's principia mathematica
it's a simulation model and here's a
real physical system that I bought for
at on Amazon for six bucks and it's a
piece of joke okay so to a scientist if
I write down Newton's laws of motion to
describe this the model would be flawed
it doesn't describe the behavior of that
piece of junk that I bought but to an
engineer the realization is flawed and I
should have been willing to spend more
than six dollars on on Amazon to get
something and I confess I'm an engineer
I'm more interested in the latter
interpretation what about the model or
the or the realization it's just sloppy
I mean it's the balls in the middle are
supposed to stay still not really it's
supposed to work like this okay I guess
it depends on what your goals are
whether whether it's actually achieving
them okay so for cyber-physical systems
I think we need to change the question
this is of course a time-honored
tradition in academia if you don't if
you don't like the answers you're
getting change the question so my claim
is that the question is not whether
deterministic models can describe the
behavior of cyber-physical systems with
high fidelity okay I think if we ask
that question the answer today is no
deterministic models cannot describe the
behavior of these systems with high
fidelity and hence were stuck with
Boeing's approach of stockpiling the
micro processors for 50 years
okay but if we change the question to
this one whether we can build
cyber-physical systems whose behavior
matches that of a deterministic model
with high probability
I firmly believe that the answer to this
question is yes okay
and I also claim that
well what about resilience and
adaptability deterministic models don't
eliminate the need for robust fault
tolerant designs every system is going
to be subject to Murphy's Law in fact I
would claim that deterministic models
enable such designs because they make it
clear what it means to have a fault
right if you have a deterministic model
you have a clear definition of what a
correct behavior is you now know what an
incorrect behavior is it's the
compliment of the correct behavior if
you can detect that you can add app to
it and react to it okay if you don't
have a deterministic model what do you
mean by a fault at that point that's a
problem now I'm pretty much out of time
so I can't really tell you the existence
proof which is another project that
ended last year called that we called
tides that showed in fact that you could
design cyber-physical systems that start
as a deterministic model for which we do
have a faithful realization that is
cost-effective okay the key idea is that
it uses time-stamped events on streams
and that the time stamps acquire a
global meaning through synchronized
clocks okay so specifically if we can
assume a bound on the clock
synchronization error 80 Pico seconds
for CERN one microsecond for us mere
mortals okay we can assume it and we can
assume a bound on Network latency then
we can ensure that events are always
processed in timestamp order so we get
deterministic streams if in addition we
can assume bounds on execution time for
example using prep machines then we can
also ensure that events are delivered to
actuators on time and consequently we
can get deterministic interactions with
the physical world now these are three
strong assumptions right what if the
assumptions aren't satisfied so here's
none synchronized clocks right here on
the Clark Kerr campus
okay again we're talking we need to
understand the distinction between the
model and the thing being modeled and
the fact is that anyone who designs
these cyber-physical systems is already
making these assumptions it's just
they're not making them explicitly okay
they need the same assumptions we're
trying to make those assumptions
explicit okay
and this also clarifies what a fault is
okay so from my perspective these are
six possible interpretations of what
real time is two are very uninteresting
one is unachievable
with today's technology that leaves
three all of which I believe are really
quite interesting and require a lot more
work of course so my claim is that the
foundations for real-time computing are
really weak today like this piece of
crap engineering and we have existence
proofs that a sound notion of real time
computation is actually possible and
practical thanks Rick I certainly the
streaming level that you talked about is
very relevant to what this whole meeting
and program
the time stamps you have all of these
logical models which involve partial
order around operations or assertions
about how certain things will never
happen but without the need to have a
clock I think for many applications you
you don't need time stamps and so I I
believe there's a large class of systems
where you can just live in the world of
streaming data without associating time
to them but that does not include
cyber-physical systems which is a very
large class of systems and the reason it
doesn't include them is that cyber
physical systems fundamentally have an
interaction and usually it's a
closed-loop interaction and you're
interested in the closed loop dynamics
of the system not just the open loop
dynamics so it's the the certain talk
yesterday was all about collecting data
there was no closed loop there was no
effect on the physical world okay if
you're just collecting data then yeah
you probably don't need well you might
want timestamps just to know when things
happened you think might still want
timestamps but they're not an essential
part of the semantics anymore well
actually my question was very similar
and you sort of answered part of it but
still I understand that you need time
for the physical world and internally
maybe just be the order that matters but
is there some sort of action where you
know because the time from the outside
rule is not going to be necessarily
completely precise the time stamp is
going to have some absolutely yeah but
of course all models are wrong so yeah
any model of time you construct is going
to be is going to have you know some
mismatch with the physical world but you
you you raise a very good point which is
that when you're within the world of
computation most of the timing actually
doesn't matter in fact the only place
that timing matters in computation is
when you're interacting with the
physical world this but this observation
by the way is completely missing in
almost all of the papers that you read
in the classic real time computing world
you know they talk about scheduling
tasks and they talk about the timing of
these tasks even when the tasks
no interaction with the physical world
well who cares what the timing is you
really only care at the boundaries
between the physical world and the
computation and so tides the model and
tides does that okay in fact the only
place that that timing so timing comes
in the connection between timing at the
physical world is that if you have a
sensor wrapped by software you timestamp
its data using your local clock okay the
clocks are synchronized but not
perfectly so the you have to have a
bound on the clock synchronization error
to understand how the overall semantics
works okay
similarly at actuators we deliver
time-stamped events and those timestamps
are interpreted as a command to the
actuator to perform an action at a
physical time corresponding to the
timestamp according to the local clock
everything in between is now an untimed
computation the timestamps are still
there they're carried through and
they're part of the semantics of the
execution okay but when the execution
gets done is irrelevant at least modulo
delivering the events here to here on
time yes so you mentioned it
well among other things you can
orchestrate the use of networking so
think of the way for example that we use
Wi-Fi today right it's a Wild West you
turn on your radio and you start
transmitting and you collide with
everybody and you back off and you try
again right think about it if you you
know if you play tennis right suppose
that we allocated tennis courts that way
right you would need a lot more tennis
courts in order to for anyone to really
be able to play tennis without waiting
around for enormous amounts of time
right so you have to over-engineer
systems and you you lose capacity due to
this lack of orchestration but if you
have synchronized clocks you can
orchestrate uses of shared resources so
you could design distributed software in
a very different way if you could rely
on your clock being synchronized with
all of the other pieces of software that
you're interacting with over the network
so Google did this Google no no they're
not fully synchronous that's it that's a
mistake so Google actually reinvented
this same technique tides and published
it in 2012 describing a system that they
call spanner okay and spanner is a
distributed database system it's it's
meant for databases with replicated data
that are in different data centers so
imagine that you've got a data center in
Seattle and a data center in Dallas and
both of them are getting queries so for
example a query comes into Dallas asking
whether an airline seat is available and
a query comes into Seattle trying to
reserve the same airline seat okay what
should the database do both Seattle and
Dallas have copies of the current state
okay so in spanner what they do is they
synchronize the clocks in Seattle in
Dallas using the same technology that
CERN used okay I Tripoli 1588 precision
time protocol and they timestamp the
queries and now they define the
semantics of the database to be
dependent on the numerical order of
these two timestamps if the timestamp in
see in Dallas is lower than the
timestamp in Seattle then Dallas should
respond that the year that the seat is
free
okay otherwise it should respond that
the seat is occupied now the question is
how how should Dallas respond well with
this technique all that Dallas has to do
is it timestamps the query and then it
watches its local clock and when its
local clock hits a threshold it responds
that the database that the seat is free
okay it doesn't have to communicate with
Seattle to issue that response so it's a
beautiful technique that it reduces it
does orchestration over networks without
communication so if you have
synchronized clocks you can you can you
can coordinate without communicating
which is a very powerful thing I believe
it is in fact these tides models are are
built as discrete event simulation and
they build on the very long tradition of
simulation okay people have used
discrete event simulation back since the
1970s to describe the behaviors of
complicated systems these you build the
model as if it were a simulation you can
run a simulation okay but we treat it
not as just a simulation but as source
code so we then compile that model into
something that's executable on a
platform and we guarantee under the
assumptions the three assumptions
synchronized clocks with bounded error
bounded latency and bounded execution
time under those three assumptions the
compiled code will behave exactly like
the simulation
if you've any questions offline